of the biggest crowd I've ever seen
January
sixth they were there largely to protest
a corrupt and rigged and stolen election
Democrats can say there needs to be
unrest in the streets but they're going
to impeach the president for saying
peacefully and patriotically making
dessert whenever they take a clip from
president Trump they always leave out
that ending clip of let's March
peacefully and patriotically to the
Capitol that's just the key point that
yes there was a pro-trump rally at which
the president spoke and you can we can
absolutely talk about all the things the
president said there but the the idea
that that rally is the thing that got
out of hand and that somehow resulted in
the breaching of the capital that rally
was very far from the Capitol and the
people who as you say did the initial
breach that allowed everybody else to
come in they never even went to that
rally why aren't they investigating
massive election fraud and
irregularities instead of investigating
the people who want to get to the bottom
of a rigged and stolen election doj
announced that the FBI and the
Pennsylvania State Police are
investigating fraud in mail-in ballots
in Luzerne County that's a place Donald
Trump won by double digits four years
ago they are saying that there was a
batch of ballots where 60 percent had
the same signature they were saying that
35 ballots had no voter record but they
were counted anyway that 50 ballots were
run multiple times in Nevada at least
ten thousand nine residents were allowed
to send in ballots for counting there
what in doj several military ballots
were quote discarded
investigators have recovered a total of
nine ballots so far not surprising the
doj says an overwhelming majority of
those ballots were cast for Guess Who
Donald Trump the elections are totally
corrupt in our country they have been
for a long time but never like they were
this last time